[Musique]
bienvenue non pas sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire mais chez moi
confinement oblige je reçois ont cédé
dans cette émission antoine flahault le
qui dirige l'institut de santé globale à
l'université de genève bonjour antony
géros merci de nous recevoir
bonjour jeune docteur en médecine et en
bio mathématiques épidémiologistes
professeur de santé publique
vous travaillez sur la surveillance
électronique des maladies sur
l'épidémiologie prévisionnel j'aimerais
d'abord qu'on revienne sur la grille
hong kong
la première pandémie der moderne celle
des transports aériens tout le monde l'a
oublié aujourd'hui vous avez ressorti
les chiffres récemment la mortalité qui
a été guérie d'enfance et plus de 31
mille morts oui en effet cette grippe
avaient déferlé sur le monde un petit
peu de la façon dont tu aujourd'hui ce
coronavirus nous nous attaquent pays
après pays on a pu même retracé il ya eu
des des modèles mathématiques qui ont
été développé par une équipe américano
soviétique c'était très rare à l'époque
d'ailleurs les soviétiques étaient très
en pointe sur ces modèles mathématiques
de diffusion d'épidémie de maladies
infectieuses et on a pu retracer
historiquement rétrospectivement de
façon très fine notre âge est ce virus
de ville en ville de pays en pays sur
l'ensemble de la planète tout le monde a
été infecté par ce virus
il n'a pas laissé comme vous dites une
souvenirs dans les mémoires collectives
très très importantes alors qu'on parle
beaucoup de la grippe espagnole sara
chacun quelque chose c'était une l'est
beaucoup moins dangereuse que la grippe
espagnole
c'était l'apparition de ce virus qu'on
va appeler h3n2 à partir de ce moment là
pour la première fois sur la planète et
c'est un virus qui est très mortifère
chez les personnes très âgées
peut-être que à cause de cela on ne
semblait pas préoccupé autant qu'on
aurait pu s'en préoccuper mais il a fait
je dirais deux fois plus de morts en
france que là
la canicule de 2003 en effet d'être en
termes il mort deux mois en 1969 en
france cinquante mille aux etats-unis 1
millions dans le monde
les liens d'articles de libération par
leurs 2005 qui a des à 12 17
cette grippe d'hong kong on n'avait pas
le temps de sortir les morts en france
on les entasse et dans les services de
réanimation des trains avait été annulée
faute de cheminots des écoles fermaient
calais professeur elle était malade et
de l'accueil dans les pharmacies on
vaccinait sur les trottoirs les vaccins
étaient plutôt artisanaux et peu
efficace en france mais on a quand même
pas porter plainte contre le
gouvernement encore moins contre les
médecins ou l'industrie pharmaceutique
une courte et pas les morts l époque
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça qu'on va
oublier ce qui s'était passé alors on
comptait les morts mais c'était un peu
compliqué à comprendre mais la mortalité
par grippe
généralement il en particulier par cette
grippe la grippe h3n2 n'est pas une
mortalité le plus souvent qui est
directe c'est-à-dire que vous savez pour
le coronavirus les gens on voit bien on
a des rapports tous les jours deux
personnalités ou de personnes donc tour
nous décrit les caractéristiques de la
maladie jusqu'à la mort en fait il
rentre à l'hôpital ils sont essoufflés
ils ont de menie virale et puis il
arrive en insuffisance respiratoire en
détresse respiratoire aiguë et parfois
la réanimation ne les sauve pas c'est
très clair la chaîne de causalité entre
le virus et la mort pour la grippe c'est
beaucoup plus direct dans bien des cas
bien sûr ce type de de mortalité peut
arriver mais il est exceptionnel avec la
grippe h3n2 le plus souvent la mortalité
est observé sur les courts de décès
parfois des mois qu'ils qui suivent
l'événement donc c'est pas en 1969 ce
que l'on s'est rendu compte de la
mortalité de 31 mille décès que vous
avez évoquées c'est bien plus tard
lorsqu'on a pu comparer la mortalité
pendant ces deux mois d'épidémie très
sévère qui avaient été enregistrés sur
le territoire national on a pu voir par
les laboratoires de virologie que des
virus de cette grippe là avaient été
isolés exactement pendant cette période
là et on a vu une surmortalité
31 milles par rapport à la mortalité
attendue à la même époque les autres
années et donc quand on regarde les
certificats de décès il ya bien sûr
quelques décès il ya marqué morts par
grippe ou remords avec grippe mais la
plupart des décès sont en fait des
personnes très âgées qui avaient des
maladies par ailleurs et qui je dirais
c'était la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase
ils sont éteints souvent par une telle
une décompensation de leur maladie
préexistante n'est pas véritablement par
la tacc elle-même du virus dans leur
organisme ou d'une façon indirecte et
pas toujours très bien comprise
d'ailleurs frappant l'impression qu'ils
allaient passer inaperçu dans la
population
je ne pourrais les pouvoirs publics pour
les gouvernements de l'époque
en fait ou ne s'aperçoit pas qu'ils
avaient vidé me alors qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment tout le monde en est plus que
conscient
si on avait fait pareil avec les kobe de
19 aces qui aurait été votre avis
beaucoup plus mortel que ne l'a été à
l'époque la guilde hong kong
alors je ne suis pas totalement sûr de
comprendre la question mais une chose
qui est certaine c'est que au jour
d'aujourd'hui ce que l'on m'a comme un
rapport de mortalité c'est vraiment ce
qu'on appelle la mortalité directe
c'est-à-dire que les rapports qui nous
sont transmis sont des rapports de décès
pour lequel on a pu identifier
clairement que le coc vide et être la
cause du décès certainement c'est
sous-estimer parce qu'il ya des décès
qui sont certainement dû directement aux
qu'ovide et qui ne sont pas rapportés
on a vu que dans certaines ehpad ça a
été le cas mais c'est certainement le
cas dans d'autres dans d'autres endroits
on peut aujourd'hui mourir une étude new
york est très récente a peut-être paru
hier ou aujourd'hui nous renseigne sur
des mortalités par cardiomyopathie c'est
là qu'on peut croire qu'on fait un
infarctus du myocarde aujourd'hui est en
fait c'est une attaque du virus du virus
qu'ovide donc ce virus covit va avoir
des mécanismes de jeu 2-2
on appelle ça de pathogènes elle c'est à
dire de 2,2
d'induction de maladies qui ne sont pas
forcément toutes répertoriées
aujourd'hui que ce virus est nouveau et
ils vont y va donc probablement nous
donner du fil à retordre y compris dans
ce qu'on peut appeler la classification
des maladies qui peuvent entraîner la
mort donc ça c'est une première chose
mais la deuxième chose qui est assez
importante c'est que cette surmortalité
cet excès de mortalité dont j'ai parlé
pendant la période de cette grippe
pandémique de hong kong de 1968 69
eh bien elle va aussi probablement
survenir avec ce coronavirus alors en
italie les italiens en sont presque
certains nous en suisse on surveille la
surmortalité presque au jour le jour
parce que maintenant tout cela est quand
même très informatisée et on voit
comment c'est une inde et but de
surmortalité
on arrive déjà à l'enregistrer sur les
données suisses je ne sais pas quelle
hauteur quelle taille elle va avoir
c'est pas quelque chose d'exceptionnel à
chaque fois qu'il ya une épidémie de
grippe même de grippe saisonnière il y à
une surmortalité qui est enregistrée
quand il ya une canicule on l'a vu il ya
également une surmortalité qui est
enregistrée donc ce que je pense c'est
qu'il va y avoir une sur mortalité
associée à l'épidémie de e vide qui
n'est pas uniquement la mortalité
directe que l'on enregistre mais on va
également sans doute très sans doute
très certainement voir des décès par
exemple de personnes qui à cause de
l'engorgement du système de santé dans
certains endroits peut-être dans
certaines régions de france
peut-être dans certaines régions
d'europe peut-être à new york
aujourd'hui il est possible que
certaines pathologies soient pas prises
avec les standards actuels de traitement
je vais donner un seul exemple je
prenais l'infarctus du myocarde
si aujourd'hui vous fait un infarctus du
myocarde vous devez être prises en
charge dans les 90 minutes qui suivent
votre un parc plus et on doit vous poser
un stent si c'est le bon diagnostic dans
les 90 minutes on a pu démontrer que si
on prend du retard
la mortalité augmente sinon on peut
sauver beaucoup de vies
il est possible qu aujourd'hui ce soit
plus compliqué de traiter correctement
un infarctus du myocarde en certains
endroits où le service de santé est
engorgé justement c'était ça ma question
il est peut-être précaire en la cuisant
en se focalisant sur le
sur le corner dione risque une chorale à
telus au fond est ce que est ce que si
on ne l'avait pas fait si on avait fait
qu'au moment de la grippe dans le
contenu si je vous l'avais si on avait
fait une fonction s'était livré à une
espèce de fatalisme comme vous mais
d'une faire à l'époque
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils ont eu
beaucoup plus de morts qu il y en a
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on a eu raison au
fond de réagir aussi rapidement
on va voir que tout le monde n'a pas
réagi rapidement mais quand même il ya
eu un délai très réaction assez rapide
est à peu près dans tous tes sur toute
la planète
est ce qu'on a fait un bon calcul
certains commencent à se poser la
question est ce que vous voulez a coché
oui je pense que vous serez d'accord je
comprends cette question c'est une très
bonne question parce que la réaction
face à cette pandémie de kovy 19 a été
exceptionnel à tous points de vue je
dirais en effet sans aucun précédent
jamais le monde de façon aussi rapide
d'abord a été au courant des choses en
1968 69 ans n'a pas l'internet bien
entendu donc on n'est pas au courant de
ce qui se passe on a bien sûr des télex
on a quand même on a quand même des
télécommunications qui fonctionne déjà
bien vous l'avez même vous le même dit
c'est la première pandémie de l'ère
moderne
il ya des avions qui intercontinentaux
qui hong kong et un hub majeur de l'asie
à l'époque tokyo également donc vraiment
on est dans l'ère moderne mais on n'est
pas dans notre ère d'aujourd'hui donc
vous avez raison de dire que les
réactions ne pouvait pas des à cette
époque-là être de même nature et la
réaction
si même réaction avait lieu ou dans
l'autre sens si on n'avait pas réagi
aujourd'hui on n'aurait pas retarder la
vague venant de vous anne de chine comme
les chinois n'ont certainement fait part
lors confinement très strictes qui l'ont
imposé à partir du 23 janvier
on aurait très certainement pas non plus
aplatie
le pic épidémique comme on l'a aplati
comme on voit comment il a été aplatie
encore et c'est très clair en suisse on
commence déjà à voir les effets très
significatif de ce confinement strict et
en france également dans tous les pays
où il est mise en place
même si nous pays souffre aujourd'hui
beau
ou parce qu'on est vraiment probablement
très près du pic épidémique ou qui est
la période la plus la plus pénible la
plus tendue malgré tout elle aurait été
plus longue à doha et et plus haute est
probablement beaucoup plus difficile à
surmonter la vague encore une fois n'est
pas complètement comparable à celle de
1968 on a un virus qui est probablement
beaucoup beaucoup plus mortifères mêmes
qui entraîne beaucoup plus de cas de
rennes de traitement en unité de soins
intensifs et de réanimation que la
grippe pandémique de 1968-69 le premier
médecin qui a alerté on sait aujourd'hui
et mon partenaire exceptionnel et commis
de 19
l'om est ce également ltd a été lent de
semble-t-il en s'opposant à certaines
restrictions départ notamment de voyages
d'échangés commerciaux avec la chine
est-ce que ça a eu des conséquences
dramatiques alors ce plan de la chine de
l'information de la chine
vous savez on a de l'information que
c'est ce qu'ils veulent bien nous donner
l'information est tout sauf transparent
tu ne l'as jamais été mais
particulièrement pour cet épisode on
avait beaucoup l'om ans à l'époque
l'avait reproché
quand j à l'époque c'était en 2003 avait
vraiment vivement reproché à la chine
la lenteur de sa gestion est même
certain déni dans dans l'émergence du
strass qui était aussi une épidémie à
coronavirus plus grave encore parce que
la mortalité était de l'ordre de 10% ce
qui est probablement dix fois supérieure
à celle de ce qu vide 19 mai malgré tout
c'était hong kong
c'était le vietnam qui s'en était rendu
compte ça n'était pas la chine qui
l'avait rapporté alors qu'eux ils
savaient très bien qu'ils avaient un
épisode très sévère de pneumonie
atypique qu'ils auraient dû rapporter
dans le cadre du règlement sanitaire
international qui est un traité qui lie
tous les états qui est contraignant et
qu'avait signé la chine donc la chine
s'était fait remettre un peu les
pendules à l'heure et avait fait amende
honorable avait congédié son ministre de
la santé il y avait un vrai séisme
politique en chine
à l'issue du strass on pouvait penser
que la chine avait retenu les leçons du
passé
rien on est je pense au jour
lui qu'on va peut-être découvrir que les
délais de notification de la chine sont
au moins aussi important que celui du
strass il ya eu beaucoup de dénis vous
avez signalé que les lanceurs d'alert
avec étaient bâillonnées tristement le
docteur li on est décédé du de ce
coronavirus je pense que ces retards est
absolument énorme et de très lourds de
conséquence il faudra attendre le 23
janvier pour que le président jean ping
décide de le confinement devone et
toutes les mesures de confinement et de
restriction des transports des des
gros-porteurs venait avec plein de
touristes jusqu'au 22 janvier essaimé
dans le monde entier parce qu'il
repartait très connecté avec l'ensemble
du monde et cela a eu certainement des
conséquences très très importante
par ailleurs je n'ai pas du tout de
confiance non plus aujourd'hui dans les
chiffres qui nous sont rapportées de
mortalité et de morbidité de décalques
confirmé 2 shin sekai existe bien sûr
mais il semble qu'ils sont extrêmement
sous-évalué et peut-être sous évalué de
façon volontaire donc on a aujourd'hui
les données qu'on nous rapporte et on en
à extrêmement peu de confiance
une unité est sûre nous manque c'est
logique c'est ce qui caractérise les
dictatures c'est leur pouvoir vous
mentir l'homme et sa lenteur
est ce qu'elle a écrit si l'on dit
d'accord alors louer mais ce n'est pas
tellement sa lenteur le problème parce
que noël massa a été prévenue le 1er
janvier je crois que l a déclaré une
urgence de santé publique de portée
internationale parmi les premières enfin
les plus rapidement possible parmi les
quelques événements de ce genre qui
avait été déclarée on lui avait reproché
sa lenteur pour ebola pour ebola
médecins sans frontières avait quand
c'était en afrique de l'ouest dans les
années 2014 de médecins sans frontières
avait alerté de cet épisode d'ebola en
disant que c'était très grave parce que
c'était en afrique de l'ouest on n'avait
jamais eu à cette époque là il y avait
des villes et des communautés
importantes mais on lui avait reproché
sa lenteur vraiment au démarrage et à l'
alerte
ici on n'est pas dans le même cas de
figure oms a plutôt réagi une fois
qu'elle a été au courant a plutôt réagi
rapidement
la seule chose c'est que quand on
déclare une urgence de santé publique de
portée internationale
on actionne ce cône rappelle le
règlement sanitaire international
c'est un peu technique mais c'est un
traité comme je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure qui est contraignante et d'être
les pays s'engagent à suivre les
recommandations de l'oms
c'est contraignant mais ça ne s'appelle
que des recommandations c'est le terme
officiel de ce que peut donner comme
directive l'om est donc c'est pas des
vrais directives comme par exemple les
directives européennes qui s'applique à
la france qui va changer sa législation
pour s'adapter en fonction
là ce sont des recommandations le
problème c'est que l'ogc nice a donné
très peu de recommandation la seule
recommandation qu'elle a donné le 29
février c'était vous l'avez signalé de
ne pas fermer les frontières
pour ma part je pense que c'est une
excellente recommandations tout montre
que une fois que le virus a essaimé dans
tous les pays du monde
fermer les frontières c'est
contre-productif ça empêche la
solidarité entre les pays ça parfois ça
crée des problèmes majeurs en matière de
deux travailleurs frontaliers et c'est
donc ce n'est pas en général une
solution qui est montrée comme efficace
donc la recommandation de m s est bonne
est né va être foulé aux pieds par tout
le monde y compris par des très grands
pays y compris par l'allemagne y compris
très récemment par l'europe donc par les
états unis
et c'est donc bon les pays sont
souverains noël mais ce n'est pas
supranationale elle est vraiment
internationale des pays ont le droit
d'enfreindre ses règlements le règlement
sanitaire international qu'ils ont
pourtant signé mais l'om s ne le dit
même pas on marche sur les pieds de l'om
est celle oms ne dis pas que ça lui fait
mal
le ms ne dit pas ne reproche pas comme
elle l'a fait dans le passé
pourquoi soit soit elle doit changer son
recommandations pensant qu'elle est
obsolète ou quelle est la mettre à jour
soit probablement elle devrait dire mais
pourquoi entraîniez vous de cette façon
le règlement sanitaire international
il ne faut pas reprocher à la france que
beaucoup mensuel de base à bord mais
c'est quand il est là une raison et a
lobé irait absolument fermer les
frontières s'était enfreindre et violé
de façon totalement ouverte le règlement
sanitaire internationale après la chose
qu'on peut reprocher peut-être à l'om
est ce c'est de ne pas avoir donné des
recommandations plus précises sur les
deux mesures que les états pouvaient
prendre et dans le fond les états se
sont mises à adopter une mesure qui a
été mise en place par un état
dictatorial
la chine qui était ce fameux look
d'armes qu'on appelle en français le
confinement au script ce confinement
strict n'a jamais été déployés dans
aucun traité d'épidémiologie moi j'ai
jamais appris ce qu'était le confinement
strict on n'a pas non plus de règles de
déconfinement tout ça n'est pas enseigné
tout ça n'est pas évalué et pourtant les
pays les uns après les autres pas tous
on pourra revenir dessus mais vont
adopter comme par une sorte de
fascination l'exemple chinois comme si
ce qui s'était passé avoue anne avait
permis de contrôler la situation une
situation très très difficile assez
tragique beaucoup de morts mais on va
faire la même chose parce que on est
complètement pris par le temps
complètement dépassé et que on a ce
modèle qui nous fascine et qu'on va
impliquer dans différents pays
aujourd'hui peut-être dans la moitié de
l'humanité
effectivement la moitié de la population
est confiné et ça semblait terriblement
primitif dont il est temps que aussi
technologique que la nomme l'appelaient
ses initiatives de la chine
les peintures quelqu'un de violent
aujourd'hui que les chinois les doubles
qui les utilisent et doute la
technologie dont disposent pour puis
qu'est sa population vous voyez ça n'est
pas du tout évident que le confinement
ce soit la meilleure solution alors ça
n'est pas évident que ce soit la
meilleure solution mais ce n est pas non
plus sans aucun rationnel le rationnel
que derrière le confinement c'est ce
qu'on appelle des mesures d'intervention
non pharmaceutiques pour essayer
d'augmenter la distance sociale entre
les individus alors je vais dire ça de
façon peut-être un peu plus simple un
peu plus simplement il faut évidemment
séparer les gens qui sont infectés des
gens qui sont bien portants c'est ça
l'objectif
parce qu'en fait si vous diminuez les
contacts entre les infecter des bien
portants
pouvait espérer ça les modèles
mathématiques démontre bien mais
également l'expérience en particulier
vous dit que c'est une méthode très
archaïque c'est presque vrai sur le plan
sémantique
parce qu'en fait c'était appliqué pour
la pandémie due justement de grippe de
1918 le sait cette distance sociale que
sont la fermeture des écoles la
restriction des rassemblements le la
restriction des mouvements de la
population et voire même les cordons
sanitaires les quarantaine de régions
entières
donc quelque part c'est quelque chose
qui est prouvée comme ayant une idée
fait qu'ils s'étaient quand on a pas de
vaccin s'est donc pharmaceutique c'est
quand on a mis vaccin ni médicaments ce
qui est le cas aujourd'hui donc en
l'absence de ces vaccins il faut bien
utiliser cette augmentation de distance
sociale cette réduction du nombre de
contacts mais ce qui est archaïque c'est
de le faire avec cette façon confinement
strict en principe l'idée c'est que le
confinement strict il améliore les
choses parce que il va véritablement
garantir la réduction du nombre de
contacts et je crois que c'est vrai ce
qu'on ne sait pas céder et indésirables
peut-être que c'est vrai pour le corona
virus on va donc diminuer le risque
coronavirus ce qu'on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui c'est si on augmente
d'autres risques alcoolisation dans les
appartements confiné violence domestique
peut-être maladie mentale sans parler de
toutes les dégâts économiques sociaux
politiques qui s'en suivent alors est ce
qu'il y a d'autres solutions c'est là où
je pense qu'il faut se tourner vers ce
parce que tous les pays n'ont pas
appliqué le confinement même si la
moitié de la planète l'appliquer on peut
si vous le souhaitez se tourner vers
quelques exemples de pays qui n'ont pas
du tout appliqué cela et qui aujourd'hui
voit l'épidémie également passés chez
eux et on peut vous raconter comment ça
se passe
c'est la corée du sud s'est jamais alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils font que nous ne
faisons pas alors je vais vous montrer
des pays qui sont tous aux portes de la
chine
ces pays-là avait une avait au début
janvier une compréhension très claire de
la menace d'un virus qui aurait pu être
émerger de d'asie du sud-est ou de chine
il avait eu l'expérience du sras ce dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure qui était en
2003 après ils ont eu l'expérience du
maire ce qui est aussi arrivé d'ailleurs
en corée mais aussi en arabie saoudite
mais il est arrivé en corée et après il
ya eu l'expérience plusieurs expériences
de grippe aviaire bref la menace naledi
émergentes infectieuses de la gravité de
celle que l'on connaît coronavirus été
prises très au sérieux mais pas par les
politiques vous savez on a toujours
tendance à penser que c'est les
politiques qui font pas les choses comme
il faudrait au moment où il faudrait
mais ces politiques ils sont leur serait
le reflet de ce que nous sommes nous les
citoyens les experts vous les
journalistes enfin nous tous si tout le
monde pense que c'est de la grippe est
on a entendu beaucoup cela dans les
médias européens et américains et nord
et sud américains ces derniers temps
encore enfin tant que les gens se disent
tous ça n'est pas grave
et on sait pas plus que la grippe
saisonnière vous vous en fait beaucoup
trop
vous ne pouvez pas mobiliser votre
population vous ne pouvez pas non plus
appliqué un certain nombre de mesures
que n'accepterait pas la population et
je vais en parler si vous voulez mais à
singapour on peut prendre l'exemple de
singapour 6 millions d'habitants c'est
un petit peu moins que la suisse mais
c'est même genre c'est une ville état
c'est plus homogène c'est un peu une
manhattan en fait quand même et ils ont
pour vous dire au jour d'aujourd'hui
sont aux portes de la chine ont été les
premiers à recevoir les cas les tout
premiers cas sont arrivés à singapour de
devone en particulier îlots ils ont pris
cela dès le début ils ont développé un
plan très prévu à l'avance millimétré
avec un investissement majeur pour
repérer tous les cas un par un
pour traquer tous les contacts de ces
cas et avec tous les moyens possibles y
compris de police y compris vraiment de
très intrusif avec des des libertés
individuelles en termes de
confidentialité de vos données de votre
smartphone des caméras de rue etc qui
ont été et qui dépasse la législation
actuelle en europe par exemple on a pu
retracer ses contacts et lorsqu'on a
retrouvé des contacts harris qu'ils ont
placé les contacts comme soit à haut
risque soit faible risque et quand ils
ont pu voir des contacts surtout à haut
risque ils ont essayé de les isoler de
leur foyer on ne va pas les remettre
chez eux à contaminer leurs proches
on les isole en quarantaine ont bien sûr
on les teste également donc avait une
politique de testing très très
importante est un test on teste et on
trace et oni sol
chaque cas grâce à cela singapour
aujourd'hui n'a pas fermer ses écoles
n'a pas fermé ses commerces n'a pas
fermé ses bars et ses restaurants n'a
pas fermé ses cinémas ajuste empêcher
les rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes et le travail a continué comme
d'habitude avec par ailleurs le taux de
mortalité le plus faible du monde il y a
trois décès qu'ils sont enregistrés 802
800 car aujourd'hui confirmée donc une
un tsunami qui n'est pas passée chez eux
leurs services de santé n'a pas été
débordée mais un énorme investissement a
été consacrée aux questions parce
qu'elle avait d'autres tests le prouvent
vous allez au cinéma tout est gelé en
espagne 5 de spectacles vitesse et après
on crasse tous les gens qui devaient
déclarer qui contraste les gens qui est
marrant mais c'est parce qu'il a eu des
catholiques et s'ils sont pas les tests
qu'on pouvait voir donc
9-10 ans depuis le depuis les
illustrations du h1n1 ils les ont
fabriqués à toute allure et pourquoi que
nous ne vous dis pas oui alors tous les
virologues l'abattant de virologie qui
connaissent ces virus respiratoires ont
fabriqué au moment où ils ont pu avoir
le code génétique du virus qui a été
donné par les chinois très rapidement le
10 janvier
toute la communauté internationale
disposait du code génétique complet la
séquence complète du virus qui
permettait de construire ces tests donc
les tests bien sûr il ya eu une
industrie vous avez tout à fait raison
et une recherche très sophistiquée à
singapour on n'est pas en train de
parler d'un pays à faible niveau de
revenu on est évidemment dans un endroit
très très développé mais qui n'a rien à
envier à nos laboratoires de virologie
d'europe bien sûr tout le monde a su
faire le test en temps et en heure
simplement à partir du moment où vous
avez encore une fois toute une
population
toute une classe politique toute une
équipe de je dirais de d'experts et
aussi de journalistes entièrement
concentré sur un tel risque à une telle
menace l'apprenant tous au sérieux les
investissements son concept sont
consentis sans aucune difficulté
donc on développe on achète des tests
personnes se dit oui mais ça va être
encore un gaspillage on va encore
stockés des choses inutiles donc ça va
être encore des dépenses publiques sans
lendemain ils savent que c'est peut-être
des dépenses sans lendemain mais il
ils les prennent et est par ailleurs ils
savent que ça va être beaucoup beaucoup
moins coûteux à la fin des comptes que
le knock down que ce confinement strict
où l'économie est complètement dévasté
pendant plusieurs mois
d'accord
[Musique]
mais voilà de retour avec antoine
flahault qui dirige l'institut de santé
globale l université de genève
on vient de voir ce qui pour vous et a
été la meilleure
la meilleure solution c'est celle
adoptée par taiwan par des pays comme la
corée du sud hong kong ou ou le jacuzzi
d'une certaine manière le problème du
confinement que nous avons dû prendre à
défaut
d'après ce que vous dites si nous avions
eu des tests nous aurions pu faire comme
comme taïwan ou comme ou comme saga
cours nous n'en avions pas alors c'est
qu'ils ont du coup nous étions combien
coûte une bande en fait encore une fois
l'ensemble de la société n'était pas
prête
ce n'était pas préparé à une telle
menace en europe ou aux états unis
on n'a pas peut-être que le canada est
un des pays qui parmi les autres pays
nos nazis atik a connu le ne sera sa
toronto et davantage préparés que nous
mais nous finalement on n'est pas
préparé
c'est pas tellement que on n'avait pas
la capacité de le faire
c'est que on a attendu attendu attendu
que la vague arriver des fermes
quand elle est arrivée en italie là et
qu'elle a déferlé en italie du nord en
lombardie
là tous les pays d'europe je crois
c'était un peu le tournant dans la
pandémie c'est arrivé à peu près le même
jour en italie en iran en corée du sud
ça donc c'est quitter les frontières de
la chine mais je dirais que même voir
vous anne et tout ce qui s'est passé à
one n'a pas complètement convaincu la
plupart de la société encore des
segments de la société incluant les
politiques a développé un plan qui de
toute façon n'était pas prêt encore une
fois il faut pas croire que c'est de
l'improvisation de la part de ces
autorités dont un de ces pays dont on a
parlé il avait des blues avaient un plan
et l'on développé et déployé
je pense que c'est pas très compliqué
aujourd'hui on a des outils
d'intelligence artificielle qui nous
aident à repérer à tracer nos traces
informatiques de façon assez intrusive
et assez précises mais il faudrait près
faudrait déjà commencer à faire en sorte
que la législation le permettre qu' il
n'y a pas de difficulté à ce que les
télécoms transmettent à des autorités
désignées temporairement un certain
nombre de l'information qui permettrait
de retrouver ses contacts
aujourd'hui en europe c'est pas le cas
donc il faut pourquoi je dis ça
d'ailleurs c'est pas tellement pour
revenir sur l'épisode de cette première
vague qui nous est arrivé que tout le
monde essaye tant bien que mal de
d'absorber dans le contrecarrer
c'est plutôt parce que si jamais une
deuxième vague devait se reproduire à
l'automne on va le savoir assez vite on
pourra expliquer comment on va le savoir
mais on devrait le savoir assez vite
aujourd'hui on ne le sait pas mais c'est
une option c'est un scénario et si une
vague revenait à l'automne elle pourrait
avoir exactement la même taille que
celle qui nous assaillent aujourd'hui
et là je pense que il n'est plus
question de mettre toute la population
en confinement ainsi que toutes les
économies au ralenti comme c'est le cas
je pense qu'on peut trouver les
meilleures solutions qui se sont
appliqués sur la terre aujourd'hui et
essayer de les de les adopter et de les
reproduire sans doute de les adapter
également parce que par exemple il ya
des nouveaux tests qui arrive sur les
anticorps qui viendront compléter le
dispositif
mais je pense pas qu'on puisse
aujourd'hui se dire non rien n'arrivera
plus c'est terminé on connaît la recette
on va faire du lock down lockdown la
dame je ne crois pas le continent c'est
provoquer une crise économique sans
précédent on sait pas ce que ça peut
donner
en 2009 il y avait une conférence teens
de données par bill gates qui s'étonnait
que l'on ne se prépare pas
convenablement à une bombe baby comme
auparavant effectif on s'était préparé
une attaque nucléaire
le départ des troupes on avait on avait
mis des moyens on avait fait que les
alliances internationales tout ça
8 semblait nécessaire en vue du pays
pandémie mondiale dont il disait qu'il y
avait beaucoup plus de risques mettez
champ de mines afin que les cardinaux
mort dans une tournée mondiale que dans
une attaque nucléaire
on aurait dû écouter les billettes mais
je pense que 2010 qui l'écouté des gens
comme vous déjà à l'époque non non je
n'ai pas cette prétention je pense que
bill gate justement à une vision qui est
celle du xxième siècle
le confinement strict c'est la vision du
début du 20e siècle on a un siècle de
retard
en appliquant des méthodes qui sont des
méthodes certes de distanciation social
mais on peut faire de la distanciation
social de précisions on peut
véritablement aller chercher les cas
suspects aujourd'hui parce qu'on a des
diagnostics moléculaires parce qu'on a
des diagnostic biologique qui nous
permet d'aller identifié au cas par cas
peut-être qu'il faut une petite armée et
de d'enquêteurs qui va aller chercher
ses contacts à domicile et exiger d'eux
un prélèvement pour qu'on puisse être
certain qu'ils soient qu'ils sont
négatifs ou au contraire si jamais ils
sont positifs pour qu'on leur demande et
qu'on exige de la loi reprendre
l'exemple de singapour
la loi est prévue dans ce cas très
particuliers ont peu de force
si la personne n'est pas d'accord sous
la contrainte on peut véritablement
l'exclure de son foyer pendant une
période courte de quelques jours qui
permet véritablement de protéger les
biens portants et de d'augmenter cette
distance sociale d'une façon ou d'une
autre donc c'est pas non plus non
autoritaire on est dans quelque chose
qui est très intrusif
mais qui respecte l'ensemble de
l'économie après on peut avoir un débat
démocratique qu'est ce que vous préférez
on est tous dans nos appartements sans
bouger et et sans pouvoir travailler on
ferme tous les commerces tous les
marchés ont fait rage elle toute
l'économie du pays ou bien on laisse
tant que faire se peut le maximum de
cette économie vivre normalement ou à
peu près normalement
mais on accepte chacun que nos contacts
s'ils sont s'il s'avère être à risque
vont être provisoirement temporairement
dépister d'une part identifié mais
également accompagné d'un raisonnement
que l'on va consentir
ça c'est quelque chose que un pays
démocratique peut à mon avis de façon
claire décidé d'appliquer ou de ne pas
appliquer une bonne nouvelle lhuillier
de confinement c'est que vous aviez vous
important est que l'économie la vie et
on préfère la récession on préfère la
folie de nombre d'entreprises à la mort
de clients mais non personne
c'est une bonne nouvelle oui il ya une
deuxième bonne nouvelle qui accompagne
cela c'est que probablement l'impact
climatique de ces mesures en 2020 sera
incroyable ce que demandait greta
attenberg sera exaucé probablement ce
n'est pas de cette façon qu'elle le
demandaient mais sera exaucé au centuple
c'est à dire que la planète s'arrêtant
de cette façon là sans doute va
voilà on aura une purification de notre
atmosphère diminution de la charge en
carbone qui va être probablement
exceptionnel c'est en effet peut-être
les quelques bonnes nouvelles il ya
toujours un malheur toujours quelque
chose est bon flahaut la clinique du
professeur qu est-ce qui est ce parce de
chaque fois qu'il ya une épidémie on n'a
pas encore de traitement
oui vous avez raison de dire que c'est
quelque chose qui se passe à chaque fois
ce type de polémique les polémiques de
façon générale à chaque fois qu'une
crise sanitaire ou autres sont
totalement attendu la polémique de la
chloroquine disons que c'est un
médicament que je connais bien la
chloroquine personnellement je suis
presque comme le professeur raoul je
crois j'ai j'ai expérimenté la
chloroquine dans ma jeunesse j'étais en
afrique pendant plusieurs années
à titre personnel mais c'est pas comme
ça que je la connais bien je la connais
bien car comme didier rahout quand
j'étais en charge mois de l'épidémie du
chikungunya dans l'océan indien
c'était dans les années 2006 on a trouvé
un pouvoir anti viral ex vivo ex vivo ça
veut dire en fait en laboratoire
dans sur des cellules infectées par le
virus du chikungunya exactement ce qu'a
trouvé
didier rahout avec avec ce virus au
chrono virus et on était extrêmement
excité par cette découverte
et on se disait qu'on tenait là un
médicament d'ailleurs quand on a fait
une communication sur ce sujet c'était
aussi avec une équipe de marseille
la communication a été reprise dans le
journal quotidien de la réunion et de
l'île de la réunion et le grand type de
la pale de la première page c'était un
remède en vue et de ministre de la santé
de l'époque était et xavier bertrand il
nous a convoqués très enthousiaste très
excités et nous a dit que le lendemain
il autorisera il traîne une extension de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
vu les conséquences des circonstances
exceptionnelles de cette épidémie de
chikungunya qui a touché rappelons le
40% des habitants de l'île de la réunion
et nous lui avons dit c'est là où ça
m'étonne de didier rahout on a eu une
attitude complètement différente
on lui a dit mais non surtout ne faites
pas ça monsieur le ministre si vous
faites ça on n'aura jamais la
possibilité de confirmer d'efficacité de
la chloroquine chez les patients
atteints de chikungunya il nous faut
absolument faire un essai clinique
alors nos ministres début n'a pas
compris penser qu'on voulait faire de la
recherche des beaux papiers oui il
s'était dit que ce concert son conseil
le voile à la ga c'est même presque un
peu et on a essayé de convaincre
c'était quelqu'un qui nous a tout à fait
bien écouter on avait eu vraiment
beaucoup des changes qui avait précédé
il
il a tout à fait écouter il a fini par
accepter qu'on fasse cet essai clinique
on a fait un essai clinique on l'a fait
aussi un essai à nîmes chez l'animal on
avait trouvé un modèle animal qui était
le macaque de l'île maurice qui était
bien le chikungunya comme nous à s'y
méprendre donc on a administré la
chloroquine également à des macaques de
l'île maurice
et puis on l'a on a fait un essai
clinique qui prend un peu de temps le
7ème et pas très longtemps parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de patience a été assez
rapide y est c'est ça dure une semaine
ça ressemble aux gros navires us si ce
n'est que c'est dû à un moustique mais
le chikungunya quelque part ressembler
la plupart des cas étaient bénins etc
on a fait l'essai clinique résultat des
courses aucune efficacité qu est ce qu
on a été triste
vous savez on était comme didier rahout
on était pas
ça allait marcher et on était totalement
sûr voulait faire cet essai clinique
parce qu'on s'était dit on peut pas
mettre un médicament à disposition du
public sans avoir fait un bons essais
cliniques rigoureux et bien il a été
négatif et après on a regardé les
animaux les macaques 7 les macaques de
l'île maurice n'était pas à l'île
maurice on les avait rapatrié en france
dans un laboratoire sécurisé et en
région parisienne
et malheureusement ça ne marchait pas du
tout des courbes était en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que la chloroquine à une
marge thérapeutique très étroites vous
si vous donnez trois fois la dose de
chloroquine vous tuer le malade à coup
sûr c'est un médicament très très bien
toléré mais très très dangereux parce
que vous ne pouvez pas augmenter la dose
il ya d'autres médicaments comme ça le
paracétamol c'est un médicament qui est
très bien mais s'il prenait 12 fois la
dose ça vous tue également
donc c'est des médicaments qu'il faut
manier avec beaucoup de prudence mais
surtout le problème c'est que quand vous
mettez un peu de chloroquine sur des
cellules infectées vous ne savez pas du
tout la dose que vous mettez enfin vous
savez la dose mais je veux que ça
correspond pas à la dose que votre
organisme transmet aux cellules
pulmonaires malades du coronavirus donc
nous pour l'asie de chikungunya c'était
pareil on avait dans le laboratoire une
bonne efficacité mais ça ne voulait
absolument pas dire que c'était la dose
suffisante pour tuer le virus à
l'intérieur des cellules
et malheureusement on n'a pas pu
augmenter la dose il aurait peut-être
fallu faire dix fois ou quinze fois
parfois 100 fois la dose ce n'était pas
possible avec ce médicament et c'est
très dommage parce que si jamais ça
marche si la chloroquine de 10 des raul
marques sur le corps d'un virus ce sera
magique qu'est ce que c'est un
médicament pas cher c'est uniquement
facile à produire
c'est un médicament universel donc c'est
une un excellent candidat il faut
vraiment fait recette les 5 min mais je
crois que les essais sont en cours et on
verra et si jamais le médicament marché
bien ça aura été une très belle
expérience
sinon j'ai vécu au standard scientifique
et méthodologique river afin d'ouvrir le
débat
on devrait savoir assez vite
en plus il parle de quelques semaines
quand même s'il est ce que ça fonctionne
sur le grenelle virus entre nous si si
je puis me permettre
entre nous on a perdu du temps et si
vous me demandez parfois deux
de dénoncer les pertes de temps mais on
a perdu du temps parce que les 80
malades qui ont été traités par didier
rahout aurait pu être traitée dans le
cadre d'essais cliniques
je comprends même pas qu'un comité
d'éthique est acceptée qui puisse
traiter les patients en dehors d'un
essai clinique c'était pas très
compliqué pas beaucoup plus et c'est pas
beaucoup plus longs de faire exactement
la même chose mais vous savez c'est un
essai contrôlé c'est un essai où vous
êtes vous donner le médicament à pile et
face vous donner ce qu'on appelle un
placebo vous donnez rien et vous êtes
tous en aveugle que le médecin ou le
patient personne ne sait ce qu'il a et
c'est très important parce qu'on a
tellement à coeur que ça marche
le patient comme le médecin que dans une
maladie en plus sont 80% des malades
guérissent spontanément sans aucune
séquelle vous avez rapidement tendance à
attribuer le bénéfice du médicament aux
nouveaux médicaments à l'innovation à
ceux dont on parle dans les journaux
toute la journée donc ne laissait
randomisée en double aveugle il est là
pour protéger les patients il est il a
été fait véritablement cette
méthodologie mais ce n'est pas une
méthodologie froide et sans laisse en
choeur c'est une méthodologie qui est là
pour protéger le patient seller des
progrès magnifique de la médecine de ces
dernières années c'est grâce à l'essai
randomisé en double aveugle et je trouve
qu'on a perdu du temps pour la
chloroquine l'extérieur ce qu'on a fait
c'est avec le diamant princesse ago il
permet 3700 personnes qui les avaient
laissées sortir
et là on a pu constater de visu combien
étaient affectés combien vos rêves sur
le nombre d'adultes et combien et des
portes ce qu'on appelle des portants 5
il développe 400 au combien n'ont pas du
tout été touchés par le virus
qu'est ce que ça nous a appris le piano
princesse est la première chose que je
pense vous partagerez avec moi c'est que
ça nous a appris que c'était un scandale
sanitaire
un signe enfin c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinairement grave je suis un
peu étonné pour vous dire que les
journalistes n'est pas davantage
critique et 7
mise en quarantaine absolument
criminelle c'est à dire qu'on sait qu'un
virus qui tue potentiellement sachant
qu'il a tué dix personnes ont je crois
au jour d'aujourd'hui une onzième
victime
il a tué 11 personnes vous connaissez
beaucoup de bateaux de croisière où il
ya quand même on laisse quand même
marine et les gens comme ça et puis on
compte les victimes
donc moi je veux bien faire
l'épidémiologiste et compter les les
blessés et les morts enfin disons quand
même que c'est indigne du japon est un
pays riche qui aurait pu qu'est ce qu'il
aurait pu faire
il n'aurait pu examiner chacun des
patients les tester et quand ils étaient
affectés ils auraient pu les isoler
complètement du reste du bateau quand il
était malade il aurait pu les
hospitalisés et puis leur prodiguer des
soins je dis pas qu'à ce moment là il
n'y aurait pas eu de victimes peut-être
c'était pas de leur faute mais de les
laisser dans le bateau dans des
conditions qui n'étaient pas des
conditions que l'on a que l'on retrouve
dans les hôpitaux quand il ya des gens
qui ont du courant d'un virus a dit
qu'on n'a pas protégé les passagers on
n'a pas protégé les membres d'équipage
on les a simplement enfermer tous
ensemble et on a regardé en effet se
développer une épidémie alors oui c'est
quand même vraiment très très choquant
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
restera mon avis dans l'histoire comme
l'un des plus grands scandales
sanitaires de cette crise de convives 19
je veux dire c'est quelque chose de
d'inacceptable et puis d'inattendu de la
part de l'autorité japonaise qui étions
suffisamment riche pour pouvoir
s'occuper de deux de ces cas de façon
digne et là je trouve que c'était
totalement indigne donc oui bien sûr on
a appris beaucoup de choses qu'on a vues
par exemple le taux d' attaque c'est à
dire le nombre le pourcentage de la
population du bateau c'était 20 % il 20
% de cas pas au tout début mais comme on
les a laissés en quarantaine les cas se
sont développées à l'intérieur du bateau
c'est terrible ce qui s'est passé et il
ya eu 35 personnes qui ont été en
réanimation parce que quand même les
japonais s'en occupait quand il était
malade en les emmener en réanimation
on essayait de réanimer il ya eu 35
personnes en réanimation
c'est quand même alors quand on entend
déjà en dire c'était une grippette
dites-moi les grippette qui donne 35
personnes en réanimation 11 morts 700
personnes malades
enfin non c'était pas une grippette ce
qui est vraiment le coronavirus quoi
alors donc le taux des taxes et la
proportion de gens qui sont infectés par
la maladie sur la population totale
oui c'est ça alors le taux d' attaque en
principe c'est ce que vous dites
à la fin de l'épidémie une fois que la
l'ensemble de l'épidémie a déferlé sur
sur la planète
donc on pourra calculer par exemple le
taux d' attaque en france une fois que
tout sera terminé
mais on peut calculer des taux d'
attaque qu'on va dire provisoire est
finalement dans le diamond française le
taux d'attaqué de l'ordre de 20% mais il
a quand même été stoppée on n'a pas
continué on n'a pas laissé les pays ont
récupéré j'irai leurs ressortissants les
uns après les autres donc on n'a pas
laisser se déployer
donc ce qu'on peut vous dire c'est que
l'épidémie s'est quand même déployer
très rapidement et c'est assez important
parce que peut-être qu'en effet
aujourd'hui en france
aujourd'hui en suisse ou dans les
différents pays on va s'apercevoir que
déjà une partie non négligeable
peut-être 20% j'en sais rien du tout
encore de la population a été infectée
par le virus dans le fond ça veut dire
que c'est un virus très contagieux si
vous vous souvenez
les chinois parmi les autres choses
qu'ils ont voulu nier pendant longtemps
c'était la transmission interhumaine est
en fait la transmission interhumaine est
évidente elle est très très importante
le taux de mortalité
on entre alors au diamond française si
vous m'avez retenu les chiffres que j'ai
donné il ya eu un décès sur 712
personnes contaminées si vous faites la
division ça doit être autour de 1,5 on
n'est pas loin de 24 5%
les pays qui ont la plus faible
mortalité au jour d'aujourd'hui sont des
pays qui teste énormément parce qu' une
des choses qui que l'on voit c'est que
beaucoup de personnes sont
asymptomatiques dans le domaine princess
il y avait la moitié des cas confirmés
qui était à symptomatique
au moment du 10 et du diagnostic après
certains ont développé les symptômes
grosso modo il ya 30% aujourd'hui on
c'est d'après les séries qui aurait 30 %
des infections qui serait totalement
asymptomatiques ça veut dire que
finalement les gens sont infectés mais
ne le savent même pas ça peut être vous
ça peut être moi aujourd'hui on ne le
sait pas on est quand même affecté et
d'ailleurs on peut le transmettre
alors le taux d' attaque où nous perdons
le taux de mortalité que vous me
demandez si on ne le dit vise que sur
les cas confirmés sévères ou très
symptomatique
on va avoir un taux qui va paraître
beaucoup plus élevé que si on prend
vraiment comme dénominateur l'ensemble
des infections y compris les personnes
asymptomatiques
je sais pas si je suis clair je veux
dire que si on a des telles différences
de mortalité entre les pays c'est pas
que singapour traite mieux les malades
que que l'allemagne ou l'italie ou
l'espagne ou la france c'est que en
italie on est tellement débordé par le
problème que on fait des tests pas à
tous les assauts automatique de l'italie
mais on s'est quand même concentré
principalement à ceux qui avaient des
symptômes et c'était déjà beaucoup
et donc on rapporte les décès à un
périmètre plus étroit plus sévères et
donc on a l'impression que la mortalité
plus élevé on a presque un taux de
mortalité enfin un atom heart asie et
qui dépasse les 10% pendant en italie
peut-être qu'il ya une surmortalité
qu'on a évoqué initialement
mais je crois surtout qu'il ya beaucoup
de symptomatique qui ne sont pas
comptabilisés lors qu'il peut se passer
maintenant comment que de sortir du
compliment parce que ça pourrait
éternellement
cette histoire pour sortir du
confinement info ds est-ce qu'on peut
sortir du conflit alors il ya plusieurs
aspects dans votre question je pense qu
il ya un premier aspect qui est de se
dire quel est l'objectif du confinement
comme je vous ai dit le confinement il a
été mis de façon presque dans l'urgence
sans avoir une réflexion sans prendre le
temps ce qui est tout à fait normal
d'une réflexion approfondie sur
l'objectif du confinement
il ya deux objectifs possibles est ce
que l'objectif du confinement
c'est d'éviter qu'il y ait un
engorgement de notre système de santé
on va écrêté la vague et on va éviter un
engorgement au loup est ce que
l'objectif du confinement
c'est
d'endiguer complètement l'épidémie de ne
plus avoir de cas pourquoi c'est
différent c'est parce que au moment où
la vague va redescendre
je pense qu'en france et dans quelques
semaines bientôt peut-être dans quelques
jours j'espère dans quelques jours mais
peut-être disons dans quelques semaines
disons qu'en tout cas ça m'étonnerait
que au mois d'avril que nous vivons
maintenant on ne voit pas le pic et la
décroissance
si ces prévisions sont exactes
dans cette décroissance un moment se
posera la question est ce qu ont des
consignes ou pas
si l'objectif est de dire l'objectif
c'est de ne pas engorger notre système
de santé et qu'on voit une décroissance
très clair s'amorcer peut-être que on
peut commencer à lever le confinement
sous contrôle et se dire en tant que le
système est très engorgée on ne le
laisse pas mais si le système commence à
se détendre
alors on peut supporter un peu de cas en
permanence sans avoir un confinement
strict l'exemple de la corée aujourd'hui
l'accord est là tous les jours une
centaine de cas rapportés
donc elle n'a pas complètement terminé
avec cette épidémie mais au moins le
système de santé peut l'absorber
les patients peuvent être soignés avec
tous les hauts standards de qualité et
ça ne gêne pas le traitement des autres
pathologies des autres patients
donc on n'a pas un état d'urgence dans
la nation on a affaire à quelque chose
qui ne va pas durer éternellement pourra
revenir là dessus mais qui est quelque
chose que l'on peut imaginer
donc vous comprenez pourquoi je pense
qu'elle ces deux cas de figure parce que
si vous voulez qu'il y ait zéro cas zéro
risque
on l'a jamais fait avec aucune maladie
vous le faites pas pour la grippe non
plus vous pouvez rester confinés pendant
longtemps parce qu'en effet à ce moment
là il va falloir attendre qu'il ait plus
de cas du tout mais un autre
je trouve que c'est un autre objectif du
confinement il faut juste l'avoir bien
décidé d'en de façon démocratique dans
notre pays
alors maintenant vous me demandez les
scénarios je trouve qu'il ya deux
scénarios possibles
il ya un scénario qu'on va appeler mono
phase iib coûts pour être plus simple on
va dire une seule vague il n'y aurait
qu'une seule vague on est en plein
dedans
la vague concerne 50 à 70% de la
population
tout confondu je veux dire les
asymptomatiques symptomatique ont fait
des études pour ça
voir quel est le degré de l'immunisation
puis vous les études vous répondre aux
50 quand elle vous répondront 58 ans 10%
ce sera terminé
et là ce sera derrière nous ça c'est un
scénario en une seule vague
combien de temps ça te prend ça peut
prendre encore deux trois mois c'est pas
le scénario le plus gai au sens où ça
peut pourrir l'été si je puis dire mais
et puis ça va être long et puis ça va
être pénible mais c'est un scénario en
une seule vague
personnellement j'y crois pas trop mais
j'ai pas tous les éléments pour
justifier complètement pourquoi je n'y
crois pas trop mais je vais quand même
vous le dire c'est que je pense que ces
virus saisonniers ont à une saisonnalité
ces virus respiratoires excusez moi ont
une saisonnalité
ces virus respiratoires sont soumis à ce
qu'on appelle une force saisonnière très
puissante qui fait qu'il n'ya pas
d'épidémie de grippe en été dans
l'hémisphère nord et que y'en a pas en
hiver notre hiver à nous dans
l'hémisphère sud
autrement dit c'est très rare qu'à la
fin du mois d'avril
il ya encore de la grippe dans quelque
parti que ce soit de l'hémisphère nord
et moi ce que j'ai pu voir c'est qu'il
n'y avait pas beaucoup de cas dans
l'hémisphère sud
pendant notre hiver alors que
l'australie a des contacts très étroits
avec la chine la nouvelle zélande aussi
l'afrique du sud également l'argentine
du chili tous ces pays n'ont pas connu
aujourd'hui l'intensité pmi que nous
connaissons donc on peut penser que là
la force saisonnière va être puissante
en avril elle va venir aider ce
confinement strict ces mesures de
distanciation social que nous prenons en
ce moment en aplatissant encore plus la
courbe s'est pas qu'il n'y aura plus de
cas pendant l'été il y en aura peut-être
mais des petits on pourra lever le
confinement
on aura la force saisonnière qui nous
protègera mais ces freins que ce soit le
confinement où la force saisonnières ont
un inconvénient c'est que dès qu'on
l'élève ses freins l'épidémie redémarre
et si à ce moment là on peut avoir
calculé qu'on a disons 20 ou 30 %
seulement de la population comme au
diamond princess on va dire qui a été
atteinte
alors on aura peut-être à nouveau 20 ou
30 % l'année suivante c'est à dire le
même type de scénario et c'est là où je
pense que si le même type de scénario
revient à l'automne ou à l'hiver
prochain
on doit se préparer on serait vraiment
coupable à ce moment là de ne pas s'être
préparés à l'affronter d'une façon 21e
siècle avec tous les éléments et les
outils l'arsenal législatif temporaire
nous permettant d'appliquer des mesures
qui ont été appliqués à taïwan singapour
à hong kong au japon ou en corée du sud
du traçage des masques aussi les basses
que c'est très important
les masses c'est très important non pas
pour la distance sociale c'est pour
diminuer la probabilité de transmission
pour diminuer la probabilité de
transmission du virus entre le virus et
vous vous avez deux trois choses
vous avez les masques masque chirurgical
le mas tout pète vous avez je dirais
presque tout masque qui absorbe les
gouttelettes de postillons parce que
c'est par ces gouttelettes qu'on ait
contaminé vous avez le lavage des mains
parce que ces gouttelettes elle retombe
sur les claviers sur les iphone sur les
tables etc
les poignées donc le lavage des mains et
puis vous avez les parts du mans où le
l'atout dans le coude c'est à dire des
règles d'hygiène tout bête qui font que
vos postillons ne se répande pas partout
chaque fois que vous éternuez vous
toussez ces trois règles permet de
diminuer la probabilité de transmission
est donc ce fameux taux de reproduction
dont on a parlé au début et c'est grâce
à ces mesures que l'on peut
véritablement contribué à contraindre
d'épidémie a diminué et voilà si on n'a
pas de masque on dit on n'a pas de masse
qui ont peut pas démettre ne dis pas que
les masques ne servent à rien des
masques servent les masques ils ont été
prouvés scientifiquement comme utile en
milieu hospitalier
c'est à dire que tous les personnels
hospitaliers on a su c'est d'ailleurs
des enquêtes qui ont été menées à
singapour pour le strass il avait très
bien montré que les personnels qui
mettait des masques qui se laver les
mains ou qui mettait des gants elles
n'étaient pas contaminés alors que ceux
qui ne le faisait pas bien ou alors pour
les personnels hospitaliers parfois il
faut mettre aussi des lunettes ou d
empêcher les projections dans les dents
les conjonctive 1 mais pour les
personnels qui ne se protégeait pas eh
bien il te risquait d'être atteint donc
quelque part on est près du préservatif
c'est le préservatif du coronavirus le
masque
oui tous les asiatiques mais des masques
dans la rue c'est vrai que ça n'a jamais
été évaluée dans la rue on a valu à
l'hôpital n'a pas évalué dans la rue bon
ben voilà on pourra peut-être maintenant
évaluer ce serait bien mais le masque
c'est vraiment un moyen qui permet de
diminuer la probabilité de transmission
du virus
quand vous êtes malade ou quand vous
êtes face à un malade
merci à palau merci de nous avoir
expliqué tout ça et je vous rappellerai
quand ça a commencé à diminuer on
reparlera de tout ce que ce que vous
voyez de votre institut à genève merci
encore de cette heure que vous avez
passé avec nous merci de nous avoir
suivis au prochain numéro
merci
[Musique]